foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar 22x
assays revolutionalized and still
turning duraclone dry regions for flow
cytometry
I am antonina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Beckman culture Life Sciences to
learn more please visit beckman.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Michael Kapinski senior marketing
manager at Beckman culture life sciences
Michael you may now begin your
presentation
yeah hello everybody thanks for the kind
introduction my name is Micah Kapinski
I'm Rebecca Makuta Life Sciences as a
product manager specifically for the
dura clone and directive kits so
obviously this is what I would like to
talk about today however I don't want to
make it a marketing message just
marketing pitch today the idea is really
just to Showcase all the different areas
of research where these kids can be very
efficiently
applied so I really would like to let
research work and published results
speak for the kids rather than pitching
my marketing messages today
okay so let's start next slide is just
obligatory
mandatory slide
we can quickly skip that
yeah before I go into all these examples
of dual clone supported research in a
monarchology infection and Immunity and
in immune modulation I would like to
take a step back first and talk about
the origins of this concept which is the
one study a large international study
that developed a very efficient very
robust way of standardizing flow
cytometry together with backman quarter
and finally at the end
of this presentation I would go like to
go a little bit beyond just the examples
being a little bit more General again
and try to put a spotlight a little bit
what it means to data analysis if you
have the luxury to work with really
highly standardized flow cytometry
essays and finally of course there will
be a wrap up and some time for question
and answers
but let's get into the one study first
I would like to pick up a statement here
in the beginning from Francis s Collins
who was directing the NIH from 2009 to
2021 and really puts an emphasis here on
the importance of reproducibility so
when a result can be reproduced by
multiple scientists it validates the
original results and the Readiness to
progress to the next phase of research
to ask the next question
um in order to really value this
sentence it might make sense to invert
it and to think about what would happen
to results that cannot be reproduced by
multiple sciences that fail to be
reproduced
you may ask yourself would this be the
results that
would
be the basis of asking the next question
would this be really impactful results
so probably not I think the importance
of reproducibility of results cannot be
overemphasized and basically this ties
back to the level of robustness and
standardization that you apply when
doing your research when designing your
essays and yeah your experimental setup
the one study Consortium which consists
of the entities as we see on the lower
left
was very well aware of the importance of
standardization and they took this as a
real
Central prerequisite for the success of
their study intentions of their idea
that they wanted to study in this
International setting which was to
induce tolerance via cellular agents in
kidney recipients using a variety of
different living drugs to do this but
just one unitized way of analyzing the
results
so they stated in their paper method
paper from 2013 that to be able to
compare
the effectiveness and of alternative
cellular Therapeutics the
standardization of immune monitoring
essays is critical so they absolutely
recognized that these results between
the different cellular approaches could
only be compared if the immune
monitoring essays would be very well
standardized and therefore the one study
Consortium developed together with
aspect Makuta Life Sciences a very
robust immune monitoring procedure that
is laid down in this paper that you see
here on the left
which is today recognized as a golden
reference standard in multi-site
standardization for flow cytometry where
MacBook router proudly provided the
whole flow cytometry solution to this
Aid Center study
however not only the methods were
published and gained a lot of attention
but also the results of course which is
finally the import more important
objective the results from this one
study were published in a very high
impact paper in the landsat and of
course this is the result of
standardization also across all centers
not only including Flow side geometry
all the other methods of course but thus
these results could really get the
impact that they deserve as they now can
be the basis for asking further
questions for asking the next questions
due to using very highly standardized
methods
on our side at Beckman Coulter the
aftermath of this standardization
efforts at the one study were to convert
liquid cocktails where you can of course
apply a certain level of standardization
into something that would be even much
more robust and unbreakable which are
dry formats that run under the brand of
dura Innovation dry unitized reagent
assays at Wegman Coulter so this is
related to a specific technology to dry
down
multi-color antibody mixes and also dry
stimulation mixes into a layer into a
bottom as you see on the upper right so
that's not a live realization technology
and this layer would be firmly attached
to the essay container and just by
adding your sample you would dissolve
the layer and you would basically be
back in the world of very conventional
flow cytometry now from following up the
standard protocols to process the sample
so with this technology we have
developed 22 catalog products that run
under the brand of duraclone these are
as you see ready to use products
antibody panel stimulation mixes where
we have made sure that they are not only
compatible with pre-enriched cell
suspensions such as pbmcs but also
compatible with whole blood so really
the native materials
um we made sure that the protocols are
streamlined so that they do not only
eliminate antibody pipe petting but
would also spare wash steps wherever
possible
um find Smart configurations to get away
from the need to compensate this bill
over between the different die emissions
so really thinking very holistic about
it to make it very simple and easy to
manage also for non-experts that is all
part of this design for
multi-institutional studies for studies
that go over long time longitudinal
settings where operators change and
basically you really make have to make
sure that the possibility for an
operator to do different than another
one is minimized and within this Dura
clone program we have five families as
you see on the left I am for immune
system research iaf for immune
functional essays that to be seen
together with directive which is dry
stimulation mixes for immune activation
and we have a series called duraclon re
for Relevant detection looking into very
small populations
um in front of a background of a huge
number of normal cells to find those
small population that is abnormal and
then duraclone stem cell SC for adult
stem cell research
I already mentioned
that the dura clone kits and directive
kits have been tested also to work with
whole blood so why did I emphasize this
so much there's a good portion in the
scientific community that thinks if you
do not decompose the sample by pbmc
isolation do not wash away also suitable
components that are imported in cellular
interaction you might end up with a
situation that is much closer to the
physiological situation than you would
see with pbmcs
and so we took the step like the one
study and make sure that all these
essays are applicable with whole blood
samples and this also includes which is
often a reason for not going with whole
blood this also includes cryopreserved
samples where now whole blood freezing
methods are out there and here in this
paper that I'm showing here on the
screen it was demonstrated that a whole
range of different dual clones was
tested with whole blood or Frozen whole
blood samples and
could show very very similar results to
the native materials so here we have
compatibility with Native whole blood as
well as with cryopreserved whole blood
once again I would like to make the case
for standardization the importance of
standardization of flow cytometry to
really generate impactful clinical
research impactful research results
so if you can rely on a
very well standardized essay to assess
potentially relevant immune parameters
you might be able to find a correlation
a correspondence between certain immune
signatures and the efficacy of a certain
treatment or side effects that are
associated with this treatment
I'm giving you the possibility to
articulate a hypothesis to predict the
outcome of a certain treatment to
predict the chance of success with such
a treatment on the other side you might
also get into the situation that you can
hypothesize
again articulate a hypothesize a
hypothesis to prevent side effects which
in turn then could be verified by adding
new data sets from the same standard
diet method so that your correlationship
between these things that you are
speculating here can be really proven
and that is what impactful clinical
research is about that you end up with
something that can be really applied and
that can lead to
clinical development development of
diagnostic personalized treatments
let's go to some proof points now as I
said already I don't want to spend a lot
of time today to talk about the values
and features of duraclone I want rather
to let research speak how this can be
used very efficiently and how
supportive this can be of your research
the first example out of immuno oncology
I would like to Showcase here is from
this group around James Hutchinson who
demonstrated that by analyzing the
T-cell compartment they can identify a
certain signature that would be would be
predictive for the development of
inflammatory side effects in dual
checkpoint therapy
on the upper left we may see that
inflammatory side effects into a
checkpoint therapy are not rare So three
around 70 percent of all patients
treated with dual checkpoint therapy
would develop such uh complications this
might be a single complication only but
we also see that this might be more
severe with a combination of several
complications several inflammatory side
effects so it's a very relevant question
to understand how we
could basically
predict if a patient under treatment has
a high likelihood to develop such
complications or not
and using the int cell subset tube among
some other tubes Hutchinson and
colleagues were able to identify that a
certain subpopulation of the CD4
positive T helper cell compartment or
the proportion of this subpopulation
could be a predictor of the development
of hepatitis in dual checkpoint therapy
and here's some more detail to that they
specially observed that this hepatitis
or hepatitis as a side effect would
occur more often in autumn and winter
time
so in a time when the patient would be
more prone to viral infections and
taking it from there they found that the
predictive power of the proportion of
the effect to memory CD4 T Cell subset
was much more stronger if they would
look into patients with a reactivated
CMV infection only as you see here in
this red box
and
the difference between looking at all
patients and only the CMV positive
patients can also be seen by the areas
under the curve where the red area under
the curve is much larger and represents
only the CNB positive cases
so if they would combine the information
about CMV reactivation and the
information obtained from the int cell
substitute
which is the proportions in the the
proportions in the CD4 T cell
compartment they could come up to a
situation that is depicted on the upper
right where and with a threshold of 16
percent
of effective memory cells in the CD4
compartment they could decide whether a
patient would have a high risk to
develop hepatitis or not
um I think that's that's a very
impressive finding regarding the fact
that you don't need any further clinical
data to to do this decision just the
same view reactivation and the T Cell
subset compartment so just immunological
data would put you in into a position to
do such a such a strong prediction here
let's go to the next case car T says I
think our T cells are all around
everybody has heard of it it's basically
on the the speaker list of any uh any
flow cytometry related meeting that you
have katisas will be on there
and here I would like to present a paper
that looks at cartesa's as they are
produced so cartesia products but also
about on the fate of car T cells post
infusion so what happens to those
cartesians once they are back into the
patient and for these purposes
the group developed
immune monitoring antibody panels
to monitor car T cells
and here's how the group sees the
application of dry reagents or the
benefit of dry reagents for their
specific research purpose
so on the left you would see the typical
situation of single color antibodies
normally you would cocktail from those
to do your your essays with all the
possibilities to introduce error and
variability and contaminations
however
um we as a high quality manufacturer can
take also these antibodies and formulate
the dura clone or custom dry
formulations unitized already in this
sample while
now there would be room temperature
stable so very easy Logistics and
storage
um while this is a highly standardized
solution still you would have the
flexibility to add antibodies to adapt
this to your specific research question
and then there you are you would add the
patient sample it would just follow a
standard flow cytometry protocol so very
classical however all these things
associated with this barric of single
color antibodies on the left or these
error-prone procedures these potential
prepping errors all this would be taken
away because you can rely on the dry
formulation of the cocktail already
and here's an excerpt of what was done
in this study you see there are some
lines that have blue cells these blue
cells represent the constituents of a
catalog to a clone tube so something
that you simply could order like a
single antibody
and the cells the lines with the green
cells these would represent dry
formulations custom made for this
purpose here
you see there are yellow cells and all
the lines
yellow cells would represent the
drop-ins that were used in order to
adapt the framework that was there
already either by catalog or custom
to a specific research question
a specific drop-in I would like to
highlight here in the red frame that is
the car cd19
so into this framework of custom or dry
duraclone you could put your probe of
question so this could be a probe that
recognizes car cd19 expression the
Target on the target cells or it could
also be a bcma car so any car would
basically be able to be any car probe
would basically be able to be dropped in
here into this highly standardized
framework
um giving you a very Universal tool to
do this kind of studies
and that's just sample how this might
look like you see here we have an
overlay of three different types of T
cells or some healthy control car
negative T cells as represented by the
black line and then the yellowish curve
stands for the patient tea sets that do
not express the car while the green
curve are the respective ones that
Express the car and you might see the
differences here let's take cd57 so the
late terminally differentiated fraction
of t-shirts is much higher in the
non-carb modified cells however on the
other side checkpoint inhibition
molecules such as lag free
such as stem free pd1
cd155 and ticket they are all higher
expressed in these tea sets in the
patient that are also car positive
of course just from assessing this we
cannot conclude and the reason behind
this and maybe the effects that matter
may arise from that but I think it's an
important finding to finally understand
what makes a car T Cell a good one a
persisting one a very effective one as
opposed to a car T cell that might
vanish very quickly that might not have
the high proliferative potential and
maybe not of great value for the
therapeutic success
that case here in immuno oncology is a
very special one because here we are
using the dura clones that have been
designed for immuno immune studies in
human now in mouth models and these are
pre-clinical humanized Mouse models so
these Mars in these Mass models we have
transplantation of a human heart
operating system that we can look at we
can study this human hematopoietic
system for instance in cancer Mouse
models
and this is how it looks like
um basically we are gating the cells on
the upper left and in the third plot
from the left we see that there are two
larger populations on each axis single
positive so here on the y-axis we see
the population that stays positive for a
mouse leukocyte marker so we have a
basically dump remove all remaining
Mouse leukocytes while on the lower
right of this plot on the x-axis we see
a large population that states positive
for the cd45 that is contained in the
duraclone and phenotype basic that we
see on the right and then all the other
contained markers that are right into
this tube can just be analyzed very
classically so we see the monocytes with
cd14 the NK cells for cd56 the T cells
for CD3 the B cells for City 19. you see
City Ford and cd8 positive T cells so
just very much the same way as we would
do in the human blood samples I think
this is really a stunning stunning use
of the dry duraclone tubes here and I'm
going to continue over the next slide
just to Showcase this example so here we
see this for B sounds where we can find
all kinds of different research just by
applying this dry tube so very easy
IMB cell
another marker that would be used to
counter stain any Mouse leukocytes and
there you are you could do your very
classical analysis on the human
hematopoietic system in the mouse by
using a highly standardized product
same here for tcrs identify alpha beta
and gamma Delta subsets and within the
Gamma Delta T cells we see the vd1 and
vd2 and all by this ready to use tube
just add the mouse sample add one marker
to basically exclude the mouse leukocyte
Mouse cells from from analysis and here
you are and finally there's a another
example here looking into T-Rex so also
for intranuclear staining of
transcription factors in the CD4
t-shirts to identify immunosuppressive
T-Rex we can use just a standardized
tool and apply this to this pre-clinical
human humanized Mouse model
let's go to a different field infection
immunity here I would like to show
functional assessment of mileage terms
of monocytes in sepsis studies where
also a Dura clone and a directive tube
is used and here I would like
similar to what the answers did like
would like to really focus a little bit
on the workflow
so we see that
the respective blood sample would be
just added to the directive tube that
contains LPS and baffle DNA so to have
tall-like receptor mediated stimulation
we incubate this for two two and a half
hours at 37 degree then we apply a
fixation permeabilization stain in the
duraclone tube and then we are acquiring
the data so along all this process we
have not
handled anything else than the sample
and maybe some washing buffer or some
per mobilization buffer we have not
handled any stimulants we have not been
freezing thawing a liquiding those we
have not pipetting any antibodies and
this overall procedure is done in a
rough roughly three hours so really
something that every non-expert can do
it's really pluck and play functional
analysis of monocytes
because
as you might see there's also no wash
step needed here in this workflow and
there's no compensation needed due to
the selection of fluorochromes that we
did so it's really fit for purpose when
it comes to multi-centric clinical
trials where the
skill set in the different sides might
be very variable doesn't matter here any
non-expert can handle that
next example infection immunity
obviously if you talk about this these
days you cannot circumvent covet covert
is very prominent still in immunological
research here infection immunity
research and here I would like to show a
paper that on the one hand showed that
neutrophy function or differences in
neutrophil function are associated with
different causes of disease here but
also other changes or other deviations
in the compartments the immune
compartments here the B cell
compartments are associated
with the severity of cause of disease
here
so with the IMB cell tube that you
already have seen in the mouse
experiments which is an a color tube a
relatively simple tube we can have a
very high resolution analysis of the B
cell compartment already as you see on
the upper right using the Muma
projections here
furthermore we can cluster by this tube
hierarchically cluster all the
subpopulations as by the expression
density of the markers that you can see
here in each column and we find or the
authors find here in this study that by
doing this by clustering all these
populations in the different cohorts
they can find pretty prominent
difference between the memory unswitched
B sounds and healthy cohorts and then
covid-19 cohort with a moderate to
severe cause of the disease and the same
holds true for transitional B cells so
with this simple standardized tool we
can find out this subtle difference in
the B cell compartment and just for
completeness there was also a functional
finding with the um tendency of
neutrophils to natosis yeah so there's
also functional finding but also in the
B cell compartment as was enabled by a
highly standardized tool again the iso
tube that has been used in many other
studies and here it has this specific
purpose so very versatile use for this
type of products third example infection
immunity here we are looking at the
pro-inflammatory T Cell functionality
again in covert patients this was done
in the context of looking at the effect
on the T Cell functionality by a certain
novel therapeutic approach in covet
and what we can see here with Ellie spot
very nicely is that upon if you look uh
in in the left part of the graphs upon
stimulation with CD3 cd28 you would see
a strong induction of tnf alpha or
interferon Gamma or both of them whereas
in the patient cohort you see only very
little stimulation by cd328 with regard
to the production of the cytokines or
the mixed production of cytokines
however the early spot here does not
give us a real good explanation where
this this comes from and which of the T
Cell populations that have a great
Variety in their functions is really
important here it's really causative to
this difference in cytokine expression
and if we do this by using the AFT
activation tube and directive one we can
see that in the lower row if you look
across the different box plots you
hardly see a difference
between
the left Group which is basically the
the healthy cohort and the the patients
this row represents the response of cd8
positive cells
but
relatively strong difference come out
here if by virtue of identifying that he
help ourselves with the phenotypicating
if you just look at the T helper cells
and the T helper cells we see that the
triple negatives or the non-responsive
CD4 fraction is much larger in patients
than in healthy donors here
and we also see that specifically in
different gamma and a different gamma
tnf Alpha il2 combined production have a
strong difference a strongly pronoun
difference if you compare healthy with
patients here so this is only accessible
for flow cytometry any spot could not
deconvolute this difference here in the
cytokine response however with ift
activation tune for derivative one we
have a very Swift
uh immediately available tool just to do
this in a very highly standardized way
that could also be done between centers
and to to enlarge simply a larger cohort
immune regulation let's go now to this
field of research and specifically to
messenger stroma results so meth in
common stroma cells in culture typically
are licensed by exposure to
pro-inflammatory cytokines to basically
increase their potency to increase their
the
immunosuppressive effect that they would
have and this group here is now trying
to go a different Pathway to license the
msc's not by means of chemical messages
but a method that they call mechanical
transduction
and this Americano transduction part
that we see basically in the middle is
nothing else but a device that in a very
controlled defined way would exert shear
stress on the mscs in replacing the the
exposure to from the fluorocytokines and
then in the third part of this setting
here in immunoassays there would be a
checkup how
but if phenotype of the South has
changed and is there any change to
functionality also that we can see in
comparison to the alternative method of
Licensing or in comparison to
non-licensed cells and so on
that's what they found using the SMS and
chymer Tube when it came to the
phenotype on the left we see several
batches with negative markers that are
compared to a reference batch and we see
that there is no significant difference
basically all negative markers stay
negative upon these mechanic shear
stress and also the positive markers
that are used to identify or to verify
the the identity of mscs stay positive
and there's no change in surface
receptor expression which of course is a
very important prerequisite to consider
these mechanic treatment at all in a
culture in the cell cultural process
so
we can also use this basically in a
completely uh artificial scenario in C2
just as we would be able to use this
tool to for instance characterize
extracts from from a stormal vascular
fraction
second example for immune regulation not
only myelid cells are important in
um when installment cells are important
in tissue regeneration but also T cells
play a very important role as this paper
is showing here and in this paper IMT
cell substance Cube and iron T-Rex tube
were used to determine the ratio between
a certain subtype of effector cell and t
a certain
type of T Alpha cell the T regulatory T
cells so by identifying all these
subsets in the CD4 and cd80 cells it was
found
that specifically the ratio between
these two type of cells is
um
are very indicative of the or it has a
predictive value and when it comes to
the Natural bone healing process
so in case there is a certain balance
that is shown as the highest line in the
red box we see there's a normal healing
process if the CDA plus T effector cells
Prevail we see that there's an impact
healing and this could be pretty
dramatic while if the T regulatory cells
Prevail we even see a certain
Improvement of the healing over the
normal healing process
so this was uh an example where not only
these two populations that are
determining here the the outcome of the
process or that are basically predicting
this outcome uh not only to assess those
but also in the large study
um
basically staining all the T Cell
subcompartments the first step of course
was to identify that these populations
are important at all before you could
basically assess the ratio between them
so both steps of the process were
supported here with the highly
standardized to workload tubes
these were the examples I now would like
to add couple of comments also of a more
General nature regarding the results
that you would obtain with standardized
phenotyping essays such as the Dual
Cloud essays
um what is the impact on data analysis
if you rely on this type of on this
quality of data production
the first paper that I would like to
relate to here is out of 2018 a Canadian
group Vancouver
found that if they go by direct clone
based standardization this would enable
um enable them to create an automated
data analysis pipeline
for data that was obtained from
different operators
along time course from different sites
from different materials or pvmcs as
well as whole blood as well as
cryopreserve pbmcs and even different
instrument platforms so they found that
oops
um the power standardization was the
real enabler here and it enabled them to
directly compare data from different
studies from different centers and
operators and collected over different
time intervals so it took out a lot of
these batch effects that you typically
would observe and would hinder to apply
these type of automated analysis
platform
in this versatile way on this diverse
set of data
second here the approach or the the task
is a little bit different while in the
paper before
the idea was to generate an auto gating
that could allow you to identify all the
compartmentalization or the
subpopulations
in a very standardized way in
eliminating
the interoperator differences as good as
possible here the idea was to
generate a computational approach that
can do this to something can do
something that maybe a human operator is
not capable to do because here we are
talking about very very rare cell
populations
on the canvas of a huge background of
normal B cells and this is really really
expert work to find these cells so the
idea to have a computational assistance
in doing that is pretty pretty clear
pretty near
and what this this means we see on the
left in the upper row we have a data
example where the red cells which are
the abnormal cells have been identified
by an expert operator and in the row
below on the left
we see the same data set and the same
color coding applies here also the
malignant has a red and this is done by
an automated analysis on the data same
data sample as above and we see that the
results are
pretty much identical I think important
to say or to mention that the training
for this algorithm was done by a data
set that had not included the one that
we see here analyzed so this data was
acquired with the re ALB tube seven
markers dried again
unbreakable you could not forget to
pipette a marker or pipe had the wrong
module it's just there you just have to
add the samples and if you can rely on
such a standardized method and then have
has another strong standardization
method this algorithm that could
interpret even the data and detect and
find the right cells for you then you're
in a situation that is basically
depicted here on the right where you see
that the concordance between automated
gating and manual expert KD is excellent
down to a level of one in ten thousand
cells so really really impressive I
think how really standardization of as
much as possible as many aspects as
possible in these flow cytometry data
acquisition process us how powerful that
could be
and finally on our own behalf our
cytobank platform version 10 now also
has an auto grading module which allows
you to train the module with a couple of
data sets Center sets to apply exactly
the same gating as you as an expert
would do to this type of data sets that
you have been draining the algorithm on
and of course this would reduce and take
out a lot of variability as a proof
point you might look on the left part
where you see two groups of data
color-coded data on the left we see in
the manual stream that four different
operators as indicated by four different
colors have done gating on I think more
than 100 data sets where there were a
lot of replicates also in there not
indicated as replicates and now we see
that these replicates are
dated relatively consistently by the
same operator however when we look
across operators we already see
significant differences here and if all
these four operators had applied the
automated gating that was trained by an
excerpt of the data before then of
course we see as expected there's no
difference anymore
so I think here is we can see really the
the full
potential of this approach eliminating
variability from end to end yeah really
form preparation of the the sample and
the acquisition on the instrument down
to the analysis finally in the
statistics
yeah that's what I wanted to share with
you today maybe as a last comment before
we come to question and answers I would
like to encourage you to visit our
webpage and see the different Dura clone
products that we have as he has shown in
the five families with all the
ingredients for immune monitoring immune
function rare events stem cells so I
think we have a lot to offer here a very
broad program that could support as I
hope I could demonstrate this to you
that can support a great variety a great
broad range of different research
segments
just to wrap this up I hope I could show
that the record directive are very well
standardized approaches
they are relevant they are mentioned and
referenced in a broad range of published
research and despite this these are very
standardized tool you're still free to
add markers to this or still it's a
flexible tool for you
duraclon a directive streamline
workflows that means that we facilitate
the flow cytometry protocol to be really
manageable by non-experts which is a
strong prerequisite for doing
multi-institutional study studies where
the skill sets between different sites
clearly are variable not everybody can
hear be an expert here but with this
approach they can everybody can do it
the same way
um simply looking at the elimination of
developing an essay of running the essay
itself of managing the inventory of
single colors that you typically would
have if you look at all these aspects I
think it becomes clear that you can also
save a lot of lab resources relying on
this type of approach here and of course
if you do not pipette antibodies you
cannot make an error petting though so
as we really try to reduce human
intervention in the workflows
um with this type of approach
um we are reducing the risk of human
area and variability of cause and that
brings us back to what we saw in the
initial statement from the NIH director
uh we are basically
setting the stage
with comparable results to really ask
the next question that could Advance our
research
yeah that's what I had today for you so
I'm happy to take your questions